fifty-two seconds of credits that start
up completely silent I haven't been this
convinced that something was wrong with
my TV since the fucking Sopranos finale
[Music]
use of an early boy song in a space
montage cliche I'm left to assume
there's plenty of hand sanitizer on
board because why else would everyone be
okay with potentially exposing
themselves to the germs and microbes of
other species that they might be
vulnerable to but these guys seem war of
the woods or heard about smallpox
blankets also why is the space station
so attractive to all these alien races
how the Earth's orbit become ground zero
for interstellar vagabonds the Alpha
intergalactic space station has reached
critical mass rutger hauer ation great
Explorer Magellan the Alpha station will
journey into the unknown that's right
instead of establishing another place in
the solar system for this baby to park
we're just gonna give it the old Star
Trek treatment and send this carefully
curated mishmash of diplomatic idealism
floating off into the unknown the space
station had to be moved because it's too
big and is posing a threat to earth but
why did they shoot it off into deep
space could they just push it a little
further outside the orbit keep a solid
line of resources coming from Earth
movie tells us these pearls are an
incredible power source so basically
she's rubbing explosives on her face
somehow feeding it to an alien puppy
unlocks its facade potential but until
then it's apparently Maybelline facewash
super advanced alien race crack blurry
mirrors I moan for world establishing
and everything but the links this movie
goes to to show off what it thinks is
bitchin effects or positively avatar Ian
ah so the pearls are harvested and then
the Queen picks one with her microwave
ham to give to the princess so she can
feed it to her Pet armadillo dragon who
can then replicate amount more pearls
into the well of galaxy sauce that then
sends pulsing luminescence through the
sand arteries probably got all that
figured out wait it's taking the
princess this looking long to run to the
city they've already had time for the
big debris to hit and settle on the
ground mobilize the military and board
the
but this is just a broke off portion of
the space station there has to be at
least another entry point and she could
make an effort to find it you know also
yes there's a giant explosion headed
their way but instead of doing anything
useful
this asshole stands at the window saying
too bad so sad to the princess don't you
think we should run through our
assignment considering these two are
professional partners it's clear that
balerion went to the Harvey Weinstein
school of workplace behavior scored a
perfect 200 on my last memory test post
position discount holodeck we both know
you're quite a Ladykiller so why do you
lose interest in a girl as soon as you
win her heart cuz I'm looking for the
perfect woman
great job movie you spent the last five
minutes setting up this relationship
that I am now completely 100% rooting
against so I hope that's what you intend
it put your hand back on the joystick
dude she's already turned it down and
now is not the time for another come on
will you marry me it's not that
proposing outside a crowded chaotic
market before a mission after you've
been fighting all morning and trying to
convince her she's in love with you
isn't romantic it's just that it's dumb
really really don't
in this crazy universe of CG alien races
there were only 12 identified species
that use this market we saw at least
that many species and the opening
welcome montage alone kicks this mule T
dimensional marketplace is exactly the
kind of big idea that could have made
this movie awesome it's brilliant and
gorgeous and clever and makes me wish I
cared more about the story or characters
enough for to actually mean something
you have a dart gun that allows full
control of another beam that's awesome
and it's also never used again in the
entire film despite many times it would
come in handy if humans aren't supposed
to access certain areas why make these
areas completely accessible to humans
also a species requirement gate that
singles on humans and really serves no
other purpose
that's specious and species issed also
also does no one get alerted when an
unwanted human walks through shouldn't
Paul market cop be rocket segwaying him
off the premises by now Luke Poisson saw
all the unnecessary CGI creatures from
the Star Wars prequels and said I can
top that I lost a lot of personnel
getting this for you huh I guess that
means we'll eventually have a prequel
that flushes out that tail called igon 1
a valyrian story you have 10 seconds to
drop your guns why is I gone even
bothering to keep these two alive if
he's giving them this countdown and if
he's planning on killing them wouldn't
it make more sense to have one of his
minions do it from behind start
interrupt this great deal but I'm also
here for a noble cause alarians line
here is a callback to the conversation
between igon and the pearls
we are fighting for a noble cause I know
and I'm fighting for a noble cause to
which he didn't hear since he was
skulking around outside the room can we
all just admit these dimensional rules
or BS how did she know where the table
was that easily what if she had pushed
the button while the box was located in
the same place is something else why did
the Larian have to be invisible eyes but
she can just waltz in how did the shiny
blue people have guns without a
converter box Woodinville earrings hand
and gun always be visible forget it
here's 10 cents for a tall just so I can
watch the rest of the scene without
losing my mind wherever you are the
universe I'll find you and I will kill
you damn good to know taken is still so
popular this far into the future that
people are still quoting it valerian
survives this wait if there's some sort
of alert for valerian why is nobody
pursuing him in this dimension like
right now they know where he is and
there are guards on this side to the for
all these assholes sent on this mission
for I understand the one dude makes the
alien guard do the alien Macarena but
why are there several other minions if
this mission just involved valerian and
laurleen does this mean that the guard
just jumped off his perch as the bus
sped away can we have a moment of
silence for the random alien guard who
just showed up for work to do his job
and ended up sucking placed as some
human jump him to his death this monster
was easily able to catch up to the
transport and rip off the roof and is
also bulletproof but apparently it
needed a short break for a proper
menacing before killing fools allowing
valerian to make their escape major
valerian invited nearly 20 minutes late
you with this year late bull movie why
would there be any super specific time
frame for them to complete this mission
and even if there were one general
Hancock didn't tell them about it in
their pre machine call you can't tell me
what you'd done 17 light-years from your
rendezvous yeah well if they're only 20
minutes away does this matter all that
much they can apparently travel much
faster than the speed of light so why
don't we get you a nice treatment so you
can get your mojo back some high-grade
uranium and your weakened is new
laurleen knows absolutely nothing about
this creature except that it can convert
stuff but immediately sticks it into
this futuristic dishwasher then pieces
out without considering how it will be
affected I'm an ass for 10 days leave
right now and I'm gonna take you to the
most beautiful beach in the whole
universe look I don't hate Dane DeHaan I
just hate him in this movie it's an
awful casting choice you could literally
throw a dart by the dart board and cast
it better Ezra Miller miles teller Tom
Holland Nicholas Hoult you could have
even thrown Christopher Plummer in there
at the last second an award worked out
better than this well
come to alpha the city of a thousand
planets roll credits now it's in you
update us the Alpha station has grown 7%
this year and since it left the
terrestrial orbit it has traveled almost
700 million miles geez thanks
expositional Alexa seriously the
valerian and laura-leigh need any of
this information why did they need a
full Wikipedia entry read to them about
a place they presumably been many times
before 3236 species from the four
corners of the universe live on board
and we're going to try and show you a CG
rendering of every single one in the
next 90 minutes to the east of them the
large colony of on lights they control
information technology finance and
banking man I'm really starting to think
alpha is an extremely racist society
they keep the aliens that are good at
finance and banking in a separate
fucking part of the city this is what's
known as a walk and don't talk it's
formal name is the anti Sorkin
Declassified and make sure and do that
full view of all these people that are
in the immediate vicinity this is gonna
be a lot of fun Laura lein would be
excellent at cinema since did she leave
that her in there this whole time Jesus
I thought the mule converter had a bad
when it was confined on that tiny box I
don't think that's a very good idea for
your personal security volume ID agent
Laura Lane look after the little guy
sure their refusal to hand over the
converter is integral to the plot but
how do these two get to be such dicks
around the people who outrank them a
Farley gal it would like to give you
some info free movie needs so much
exposition literally invented an alien
species that specializes in it Alex I
need to know the attackers identity
everyone please evacuate evacuate they
don't even know what the hell the nature
of the threat is right isn't now all the
time to have all the intelligence
personnel on hand and the attack hasn't
even come close to this room so we're
the party planning to go so doors locked
we can't get out Jesus Christ how is
this guy trusted with any job here
he literally punched a button twice and
gave up
wait this was a gathering of the heads
of all the delegations on alpha I know
the pearls lock the doors but you're
telling me there's no more security or
at least backups that can find their way
into this room this breathing device
comes equipped with his own laser spider
what a very specific piece of technology
you just happen to have immediately
available for this very instance Oh
suppose the commander there's no way for
valerian to know this since he was
covered in goo during the abduction of
the commander this power run is
certainly visually stunning but didn't
we see earlier that all these
communities were spread out over the
entirety of this giant Space Station how
are they now lined up in a row also how
exactly there's putting on this helmet
all of a sudden make not so great dane
some kind of space suit Superman
81 you're sure sorry my mistake it was
number 18 horror horror movie but how
would Laura lein even make this mistake
she was directing him from above so the
door number shouldn't matter and why the
would the number be upside down anyway
also considering valerian punctured the
wall here whatever was adjacent to that
corridor or in the path that he carved
in the station is now subjected to the
cold vacuum of space seriously there are
no other ships after these assholes the
entire government knows exactly where
they are
valerian be careful reel them in before
I lose you Larry you need to go faster I
mean Laura lein has been a capable
badass up to this point but now she's
just dispensing unhelpful motherly
advice how about trying to figure out
where they're going it's our mission
that doesn't make sense sir yeah at
least I'm not the only one who thinks so
kind of that feeling about this idea in
case you didn't realize how Star Wars II
this movie was trying to be it's now
literally lifting lines from the
original trilogy okay fine the broma sir
only gets aggressive when you steal his
jellyfish but why are all of them now
upset this unnecessary underwater
undertaking reminds me that this movie
is at least 20 minutes longer than it
needs to be show it images of valerian
it will show you what it has seen so
this random jellyfish located in a sewer
on alpha can tell you where anyone is in
the universe if so how are they not one
of the most valuable commodities in the
entire city shouldn't everyone be
hunting these things like they're
hunting the converter anything else I
should know before I voluntarily stick
my head on his mouth
holy Livy you got a pg-13 rating so you
could definitely get away with Cara
Delevingne saying up its ass as she
clearly does here this is the worst
unnecessary dub since Sigourney Weaver
and Galaxy Quest Laura Lyons memory of
valerian is conveniently confined only
to his scenes in this movie these
assholes paid a lot of money to Bob to
capture this magical fucking jellyfish
but it's allowed to just wander off back
into the wall
without anyone trying to stop it map how
much longer are we gonna have to spend
with these Dobby the house Gungan
wannabes why must every sci-fi movie
find a way to Threepio us to death she
stole a vehicle she headed into the red
zone and we lost track of her and
there's not a lot left in the budget to
show you so I'm just gonna tell you
about it and let the audience imagine it
on their own
stay with me the lane hero is dead but
not really and the rescuer says some
variation of stay with me cliche also if
his condition was this dire how the hell
is valerian still alive since he crashed
sergeant enchantress got arrested
escaped custody found a little threesome
guys went down to meet Captain Bob went
on an excursion to find the jellyfish
stuck her head up the jellyfish's
magical asshole found a ship then made
it all the way over to the red zone lady
butterfly
trained agent laurleen decides to touch
the wildlife in a strange new world
she's got a bright future in the next
daylian movie i tells you sorry damn -
huh some random Fisher of men snags you
when you flat-out murder him are we sure
of all Aryan disease here isn't actually
the villain in this movie the sign is
supposed to be only recently misspelled
but why is it in English at all he's
alien speak alien miss 28th century
street party is playing in Wyclef Jean
song from 1997 I guess luc besson wanted
to revisit the last year that he
directed a good movie right spot his
best damn Club on the whole space
station one day or janitor who sneaks
onto a Gattaca space mission and the
next thing you know you're just some
alien pimp that's the breaks kids so
jolly is sole proprietor pimp bartender
and organ player in this joint the last
round of layoffs must have been rough
look I love a weird ass Rihanna
striptease as much as the next guy but
movie has time for this I lost my
partner I feel like a good 87% of this
movie is one partner trying to rescue
the other partner and the rest is filled
with an extremely flimsy a story okay
even ID pass you have my word dude she
can literally look like anyone she wants
why would she ever need an ID pass come
to think of it how is she not already
free and doing what she wants she's
basically all the best powers of
mystique and Jean Grey combined why is
her race relegated to prostitution on
parlor tricks when they could easily be
running the world hey hey hey what are
you doing I told you I needed rehearsals
this is a heavy
much better you doing good forget the
silly walk you got going on you're
having a full volume conversation within
5 feet of these extra cholesterol how do
they not hear this you picked that the
mage is trill again just now Alex was
able to pick mullerian signal up ages
ago when he made it to the surface
outside paradise alley how do these
quads run an entire delegation so how
did you come to lose your partner
because I'm stupid what do you mean all
I do is flirt and joke actually you know
balerion was working on his spaceship
and was literally in the middle of
warning laurleen about the butterflies
when she was captured these assholes
doing you've had one job chest plate I
mean I don't expect these guards to have
a chance against valerian but this dumb
bastard literally walks into a spear how
is this alien race so fearsome if
valerian can take out like 25 of them
this easily trust me on this or you
could just quickly tell her you're
making a run for the giant convenient
hole in the middle of the room
information is your friend also why
would an opening even be there a kind of
throne room has a great at disposal
system installed right in the middle of
the red carpet
how was nobody tripping over it or
falling into it during the food assembly
line before Declassified the war against
hasn't Kohn let the destruction of
Planet mule as if having these
classified files on a giant screen and
full view of the people in the room
weren't enough the general decides to
read it aloud so that the myopic staff
can get the information to movie wants
us to believe that the converter has
been safely dangling from Laura leans
belt this entire time despite her being
abducted by an alien race that would
surely have confiscated it ring engines
tell me what to do nothing agent but
death a bubble is the bullsh pity us
both bitte tude and they already bulls
show of a movie first you must have been
injured in the fight how not only did
you Elastigirl yourself around any
incoming attacks you're basically made
of slime so how do you even get injured
anyway second you sustained a
life-ending
injury and you aren't even aware of it
until seconds before you die even though
we just saw you charging at full tilt 60
seconds ago Burt what purpose does this
death even serve to the story is it
supposed to inspire valerian was there a
moment of sacrifice I missed some
brilliant wisdom that was passed on and
finally we barely even knew you you were
basically a fetish fest a costume and
then some comic relief I've seen side
characters on sitcoms with more
character development than you taking
care of it did the evil alien race with
all the Warriors just give up on trying
to find the three individuals that wiped
out their Emperor and most of the guards
they know exactly where they escaped
right the princess she's guiding me if
princess Leo has been inside valerian
and guiding him this entire time could
she not have guided him away from being
such a douche at the
beginning of the movie Jesus why didn't
they put the portal a little closer to
the emperor is there a reason they now
need to run a 5k to get over there li
hommina chose you to be the guardian of
a song damn it sure was lucky she chose
a badass like valerian to guard her soul
instead of like Fred in accounting
non-consensual sole peeping what exactly
happened our planet was a true paradise
on which we lived in harmony with the
elements well I guess now that we're
done with valerian in the movie up a
thousand side-quests it's back to more
explaining things again sure that's a
giant spaceship but enough to take out
an entire planet like that
don't you mean like some sort of star of
death to do that and a good five minutes
or so flipping switches and charging
things up and a purposely unprotected
exhaust port also what the hell first
scene of the movie showed the
destruction of the planet taking long
enough for the important pearls to get
together and for the princess to make it
all the way back to the city but the
recap shows it being in staffed
how'd the surviving pearls even get off
the planet a meal converter and the
pearl the only one Saudi managed to
salvage okay fine she happened to grab a
pearl but how exactly is one of those
converter creatures still around if they
were indigenous to mule and that planet
went full Alderaan where did the pocket
board come from yes Jesus I've seen
scooby-doo endings that were more
surprising and suspenseful just get this
over with
we lost 500,000 soldiers in a day
perhaps you knew their planet was
inhabited and you sacrificed it well
yeah I mean it sucked for the pearls but
the commander had lost half a million
people in a fucking day else is he
supposed to do I know he's an asshole
but I gotta side with commander climb on
this one I'm giving them back the
converter I'm a soldier I play by the
rules do you for the entire movie you've
ignored orders and done whatever you
want but I guess plots got a plot
sometimes all right give it to valerian
once again proves that the power of
space boners is greater than the power
of gainful employment maybe it's just me
but wouldn't you do the first
replication over like a basket or
something and then use one of those
pearls to do the one where they all fall
into the mystery goo what happens if you
accidentally drop it or don't catch one
as they fall don't you want to save one
you know just in case I know the pearls
are peaceful but come on they're walking
out to meet a group of heavily armed
humans a species they haven't had great
experiences with by the way why didn't
they bring along a couple of those
destabilizing blue goo guns contact with
the enemy give me a physical description
and do it all slow and sexy like
definitely use that gruff voice we're
picking up a signal from the 2005
module damnit movie even if they had the
ability to interact with such ancient
technology there's no way they would be
actively searching for those signals
Microsoft can barely keep their Xboxes
backwards compatible and that's within
the same decade thank you
man I must have been some punch
considering he's been out cold for the
last 15 minutes do you confirm those
orders Kanaya late the moon setting
aside the psychopathy it would take to
decide to eliminate every single alien
inhuman on board to avoid humiliation
why does he even need to the other
officer simply asked him what to do and
gave no indication he wouldn't listen
for such sleek ruthless annihilation
machines these K Tron's seem to have
Farrar mer considering we heard earlier
that this ship was located at the very
center of this giant Space Station
I hesitate to think about all the damage
it just did and thousands of lives lost
blasting out from the middle in that
short amount of time we saw our Val pal
take out all the Kate Ron's near the
pearl ship but how exactly did they win
the battle in the control room last I
saw it looked pretty grim in here even
if they got the countdown stopped that
doesn't mean it would deactivate the
cage Ron's right illyrian and Laura lein
had time during this firefight to rap
and hang the commander from this
location which is all the way over on
the other side of this compartment that
should now be directly exposed to space
happy birthday will be seriously wants
us to believe that all this happened in
the course of one day he's been in a a
woman's body did he not learn anything
no he didn't a woman spent a day in his
body I see your point but you are still
the opposite of right from the director
of Lucy
he hid it in one place he knew he could
hide something his ass come on touch it
huh come on you need human contact
engine I will not touch it I'm supposed
to mingle with tourists early would
expect us to wear a panda suit
[Music]
he slimed me velaryon answer me
major responds but first of all while
you're attacking us because you have
what we need
[Music]
tell me what's your name
open your eyes federal agent
dude
[Music]